the International Space Station is the
ultimate extreme
home space is an environment where human
beings were not meant to live the most
expensive structure humans have ever
built here in the most inhospitable
environment known to man The only reason
we can go there is by taking
technology to provide us with everything
that we need in order to stay
alive with no air food or water 250 Mi
above the Earth it's an epic engineering
challenge we as Engineers are having to
figure out how to make systems that
provide all those functions that Earth
provides in a tiny little
can
to reveal how the engineers pulled it
off we're going to take it
apart and uncover what's going on
inside how the International Space
Station and its superstructure Secrets
will help our species reach other
planets and
[Music]
Beyond
costing up to an astonishing $150
billion this is an unprecedented
home the ISS is an extraordinary feat of
engineering because not only do you have
to make this big environment that people
can live in which you you know is
non-trivial to do on Earth you have to
do it in
space it comprises millions of high-tech
components There are 16 pressurized
modules with living quarters sleeping
Bays an observation deck and six science
labs all connected via airtight
tunnels there's plenty of parking for
visitors including spots reserved for
Russian soou
capsules and the iss's lifeboats which
are on permanent standby in case of
[Music]
emergency unlike any other structure the
ISS has to provide everything its
astronauts need if it
fails they
die a human being can only survive for 3
weeks without food 3 days without water
and 3 minutes without air
for Humanity to successfully Venture
well away from Earth astronauts will
need to be
self-sufficient if the ISS can solve the
challenges it will prove humans can
truly live in
space but before anyone can take up
residence the engineers behind the ISS
had to get it into
space and it weighs a colossal 460 tons
the same as about 300 cars it would be
great if we could just build the
International Space Station on the earth
and then just blast it into space you
couldn't just fly the whole thing up
there in one one shot you had to take a
piece at a time and assemble it together
like
Lego the ISS began life as just two
modules that had to be connected in
space one built by America and the other
by
Russia the first flight actually
launched in November of
[Music]
1998 hadn't been that long since the end
of Communism in Russia and here we were
building a joint Russian us space
station so just the political Milestone
that that represented um was pretty
significant
after the intense competition of the
Space Race it's suddenly all about
collaboration the orbiting Russian
module is known as Zaria which means
Sunrise next the first American module
known as Unity sets off inside the cargo
bay of space shuttle
Endeavor lift off of the Space Shuttle
Endeavor Unity is now chasing zarya
through space at more than 177,000 mph
two modules from two superpowers are
about to dock first thing we have to do
is to open up the pale bay doors can you
imagine how important it is for these
two modules to to
M unfortunately before both modules were
launched Engineers spotted a
problem not all the pieces got to be
integrated on the ground before they
were
launched neither neither zarya nor Unity
were originally designed for the ISS
their docking systems wouldn't fit
together the Russian hatches are all
round and our hatches are all square I
mean this is fundamental to the
International Space Station and what you
have are two things that don't make and
so what do you
do well you make an adapto Lego block
connector thing the L-shaped Lego thing
they came up with with is called the
pressurized mating adapter or
PMA not only does this accommodate the
different shaped hatches it also has a
Precision engineered docking ring for
grabbing hold of another module and
perfectly aligning
it vital if a reliable air lock is to be
made this is the moment of
truth latches on the inside of the
docking ring finally make the connection
and pull the modules
together here an Endeavor we have
capture of
zarya the International Space Station is
born it was amazing I mean here we are
we got Airborne we had unity in the bay
and when we left we left a functioning
space station ready for the next module
to come up in the 20 years that follow
Engineers from all around the world join
the project building their own space
Laboratories and bigger living
quarters but every one of the modules
was constructed on Earth and it takes a
Supreme International effort to launch
them all successfully into
space took a long time to build space
station we have to fly everything up we
have to connect all the modules put them
together so that took over 40 missions
modules came from all over the world we
have the US modules from NASA we have
the Russian modules we have the Japanese
modules and the European module you name
it and it costs around $10,000 to send
every pound of weight up here from Earth
so right now we're in the Japanese
laboratory it's one laboratory out of
many here on the International Space
Station this is Columbus the European
module it has science experiments all
over you could see it looks a little bit
crowded here we are in the US laboratory
again this is a laboratory with science
experience on all of the walls here
we're going into the Russian segment be
ready you don't need a passport
either and what's cool about this module
it is actually the very first piece of
the space station that came up in
1998 it's been occupied continuously
ever since then so if you think for 18
years there has always been a human
presence in
space
today the ISS is
enormous by far the largest space
station ever
[Music]
created it's actually big enough if you
have a good pair of binoculars and when
it's flying over right overhead uh you
can actually see it normally you look at
a satellite and it's just a little dot
but the the ISS is big enough that you
can actually see it as an extended
object
[Music]
check it's so vast in fact that it would
dwarf Time
Square at an astonishing 357 by 240
ft it has more living space than a
five-bedroom
home but the larger the International
Space Station
becomes the larger a very obvious issue
becomes
too
air in space there is
none it doesn't provide um a life
support system for US Air oxygen and so
if we have uh a home in space we need to
provide all of that the average adult
breathes close to 4,000 gallons of air
per
day with a crew that can be up to nine
the ISS must Supply a huge amount of it
and it's not coming from outside those
window
Windows cruising outside the Earth's
atmosphere the International Space
Station has to provide everything the
astronauts need to live and breathable
air is first on the list
their very survival really depends on
the things that we provide them and
you're also having to deal with the fact
that at any point in time if one of your
system fails you have a very limited
amount of time to either get something
from Earth or to get back to Earth as
quickly as you
can in a crisis an emergency supply of
oxygen can be sent up by
rocket 4 3 2
with technological advances spacecraft
can now Rendevous with the ISS in 6
hours if everything goes as
[Music]
planned but even when a cargo delivery
is successful there's a price to pay the
cost of each mission is colossal almost
$200
million it's expensive to bring a
kilogram of anything up to the space
station and to spend all that money just
to bring up water and oxygen would be an
incredible waste the ISS needs to make
its own air the oxygen on the ISS can
come from um a delivery from Earth and
then they're stored in tanks but the ISS
is also capable of of generating oxygen
on board
on Earth we take air for
granted in space each astronaut must be
supplied with 1.85 lbs of oxygen per day
365 days a year to avoid
suffocating in the very heart of the ISS
is an unassuming machine about the size
of a trash
can it's this that holds the secret to
keeping AST auts
alive incredibly it generates oxygen
from nothing more than water so what
happens is you have some water you uh
feed some electricity through that water
and the electricity will split that
water into hydrogen and oxygen the
oxygen comes off as Bubbles at the
positive electrode the hydrogen at the
negative but again being in space turns
something that's straightforward on
earth into a major engineering challenge
the bubbles of gas won't come out of the
water in your high school chemistry lab
the uh the gas just bubbles up to the
surface because the gas is lighter than
the water and therefore it goes up gas
is not lighter than liquid in space
because gas doesn't have any weight and
liquid doesn't have any weight so you
produce gas bubbles and they just sit
there and what we generally do is we we
centrifuge it so you spin it all around
and the liquid being denser it doesn't
weigh anymore but it still has mass so
it's denser and it goes to the outside
and you can then separate the liquid
from the gas the hydrogen gets thrown
away gets pumped into space and the
oxygen is used for the ISS Air
Supply there's enough capacity on board
to generate 5 to 20 lbs of oxygen a
day more than enough for for the
crew in the extreme environment of space
making air is just the first challenge
the ISS has to keep
it but it's under constant threat of a
breach in its
hole there is so much space junk up
there now there's the potential for it
to puncture the outer wall of space
station I was taking pictures out one of
the
windows and it was a nice Clear Window I
came back sometime later to take another
picture and there was a great big ding
in the window about a a 5/8 of an inch
in diameter from a microm meteorite
impact and we had to take pictures
closeup pictures send it down to the
ground and it had to be analyzed to see
whether it was going to be a threat when
we
entered if you pop a hole in space
station the atmosphere is going to leave
very very quickly no atmosphere means no
oxygen and the consequences of that are
obvious
so how does the ISS deal with the threat
of colliding with
[Music]
meteorites the International Space
Station is the largest man-made object
that's ever orbited the
Earth and it's racing around our planet
at 5 m a second but on board that's hard
to
appreciate how do we sense speed if
you're in a car for instance you know
you you have the road noise you have the
wind going by you have Billboards or
trees going by your window none of that
exists in
Space the only way you get a visceral
sense of how fast I was going is you
know you're going over the Pacific Ocean
and then 10 minutes later you fly over
New York and then 10 minutes after after
that you're flying over London if the
ISS was orbiting closer to Earth we'd
all see how terrifying its speed
is it would cross the US from coast to
coast in just 10 minutes lapping the
Earth more than
5,500 times a
year it's actually traveling at
26,000 km per hour or 17,500 miles per
hour so definitely be breaking the speed
limit
right speed on Earth can be incredibly
dangerous but in space at the velocity
the ISS hurdles the consequences of a
collision can be off the scale
catastrophic space debris is going by
you at about 5 miles a second so if
there's a big piece of debris that
happens to have your number on it it's
moving so fast you'd never see
it March 23rd 2012 Mission Control
radios the
crew and uh have a velocity any idea
checking something is heading straight
for the space station the time of
closest approach of this fragment of
space debris is 11 minutes from now no
one knows how big this object
is of the station well you you do what
you're trained to do and and even though
you got woken up in the we hours of the
morning you know what the reason is the
crew must prepare the space station for
impact can you see
[Music]
yeah yeah you go through you close every
single hatch on station which takes
about 45
minutes yeah that's from which
direction yeah we don't
know the hatches can withstand a sudden
loss of pressure that would come from
the hull being breached coming up on the
6 Minute
Mark if there is a puncture any loss of
air could lead to a serious
emergency coming up on the 3 minute Mark
until the time of closest approach the
crew takes no chances they head for the
Escape Vehicles we floated into our soy
used spacecraft uh with initial
preparations for
undocking if space station were to be
hit one minute from PCA and you just
kind of hunker down and hope it doesn't
hit you and you just sit there and wait
looks like that's
it fortunately this time it's a near
Miss but the ISS cannot rely on luck the
International Space Station is designed
to work in the low earth orbit which is
full of space debris a lot of space junk
is is human-made you know they are
things that that we have put up there
satellit
largely NASA has identified more than
half a million orbiting objects that
could pose a risk to the Integrity of
the Space Station's
Hall luckily most of the stuff that's
big enough to hurt us we can track there
are a few objects up there which are too
small really to be tracked well but
they're big enough to do damage the ISS
is constantly bombarded most of the
debris is Tiny But even a halfin Fleck
of paint could inflict the same damage
as a motorcycle crashing at 60
MPH to be a viable home the ISS has to
be able to take the hit without losing
all its
air the ISS basically has a bulletproof
vest so just like a bulletproof vest
which has different layers of Kevlar
that that can rip as a bullet enters it
the ISS has different layers in its
outer skin the space station skin is
known as Whipple
Shield the outer wall is made from a
thin sheet of aluminum less than 1/10th
of an inch
thick beyond that is a blanket of woven
material and a further thin wall of
aluminum it seems too delicate to
protect the ISS from a direct
hit it turns out that a solid piece of
metal does not offer as much protective
power as if you cut that metal into very
thin sheets spread them out a little
bit when there's an impact with a
high-speed microm meteoroid it hits the
outer wall of the ISS and
pulverizes
some fragments pass through the first
layer of
aluminum which disperses some of the
energy then there are layers of Kevlar
and Nexel a ceramic fiber that's
stronger than some
metals as the fragments hit this blanket
they break up even more and don't have
enough energy to penetrate the
hull it's kind of counterintuitive when
you think about it you know that a whole
bunch of sheets of of aluminum
foil uh could somehow give you more
protection than than putting them all
together uh but that's the way it is in
in Space the Whipple Shield has
protected the space station from
micrometeoroids for over 20
years but it's ineffective against
anything
larger if a large object on a potential
Collision Course is identified the only
option is to move the whole ISS out of
its
way space command monitors most of the
space debris that is out in orbit they
notify our mission control here at Nasa
we look at that and we have a green zone
a yellow zone a Red
Zone objects that fall within the Red
Zone have a one in 10,000 chance of
hitting the ISS too dangerous to ignore
if we think that something is coming
within the Red Zone the space station
can adjust its orbit and give itself a
little boost to get out of the way small
thrusters change the iss's
trajectory but using them is
expensive now these thrusters you can
think of them almost like tiny rockets
and those Rockets are using propellant
and that propellant isn't
infinite it all has to be set up from
Earth at a cost of 10,000 ,000 per pound
of
propellant this brings Engineers face to
face with the greatest challenge of all
how to reduce the station's Reliance on
Earth the ISS can't be self-sufficient
if it relies on thrusters to
move but a clever trick hidden at its
Center means it doesn't have
to
the International Space Station has a
problem it orbits the earth every 90
minutes and has to be regularly
reoriented using thrusters is one option
but that uses a precious
propellant with the space station if
here's the Earth we we want to keep the
station usually I mean there are
sometimes exceptions but usually you
want to to keep the station in the same
relative orientation towards the Earth
so that the Copa is looking down at the
Earth and in order to do that of course
the space station is going to be
rotating once every orbit around the
Earth what the ISS needs is a way to
move that doesn't use
propellant the solution for keeping the
ISS in the right altitude and also on
track um in direction is to use
gyroscopes this is one of the iss's most
Innovative Secrets at the center of the
sprawling space lab there's a quartet of
small casings each about the size of a
small cupboard they're known as control
moment gyroscopes or
cmgs but how can they move a beast the
size of a football
field they're really really clever in
that you can change the attitude of
station without firing any
thrusters the four cmgs are mounted on a
truss near the very core of the
ISS inside each casing is a Flywheel
spinning at 6,600
RPM the flywheels create a lot of
angular momentum and simply by changing
the RPM or tilting the plane they spin
in
they transfer that momentum to the ISS
and the whole thing
moves if I were sitting here in a chair
and I had a gyroscope spinning around in
this direction and all of a sudden I put
a break on and slowed down the
gyroscope the chair would start to spin
around you know I would slow the
gyroscope around and then woo I would do
a big spin because that angular momentum
has to be conserved so these four
controlled moment gyroscopes
can move the whole of the International
Space Station and there is not one
single drop of propellant used in order
to make that movement but they do use
electricity as does just about every
piece of equipment on
board to supply the iss's total power
requirement a whopping 75 to 90 KW
Engineers cleverly exploit the Ferocious
power of the
Sun the station generates all its
electricity for free the solar panels on
the space station are absolutely
essential cuz they provide all of the
power that the station needs the panels
have to be enormous which would have
made them impossible to transport had
NASA Engineers not come up with a genius
way to get them into space what's really
impressive about the solar panels not
least their size you know around half an
acre per array but the fact that they
are actually folded and then once
they're in space they were able to be
unfolded now that's an amazing thing to
do in space together they can generate
120 KW ample for all the iss's needs and
the equivalent of powering 40 homes in
order to maximize the power you're
getting you you have to keep the solar
panels continually pointed at the sun
which means as the station is moving the
panels have to turn and so we have
gimbals if there a solar panel we can
gimbal this direction and then we can
gimbal this
Direction one of the iss's greatest
engineering triumphs it's been
generating its own power for over
177,000 hours and
counting that enables round-the-clock
air conditioning fundamental to
astronaut
survival this cannot go down it's not
like a power cut in our homes where you
know we can get a torch or light a
candle or something if this goes down
astronauts will
[Music]
die when the ISS enters the shadow
behind the Earth the temperature can
drop to below anything ever experienced
on our
planet without the protective Cocoon of
the space station the Ferocious cold
would kill astronauts in a matter of
moments conversely when in sunlight the
temperature can soar temperature and
managing temperature on the ISS is very
important if you imagine the the extreme
temperatures that you can get on the ISS
if you're facing the Sun or not could be
plus 250° or minus 250° so you have
these huge temperature exts simply
because of being sunlit or being in the
shade
and it's something that you have to keep
in mind when you're doing your
engineering of these threats overheating
is the hardest to
manage with lots of people in
electronics inside a spacecraft you tend
to generate more heat than you know what
to do with and and so the the problem in
general at least in Earth orbit is that
you've got to get rid of heat if heat
built up uncontrollably inside the ISS
it would become a deadly
incinerator so cooling the station is a
crucial
priority standard ways of cooling that
we're used to on Earth don't work uh
convection does not work conduction does
not
work conventional air con would be
ineffective scientists had to come up
with a cooling system for radiating heat
away from the
ISS it needs to be liquid based but
there's a dilemma
ideally what you'd like to be able to do
is just put it through a a water cooling
system and then get rid of that excess
heat if they tried to get rid of that
excess heat using water the water would
just freeze as soon as it went outside
into
space water is not the solution
curiously gallons of a deadly poison
is hidden inside the hull there's an
intricate network of pipes picking up
the
heat but they do carry
water the secret is the water goes
through heat
exchangers where ammonia carrying pipes
take the heat outside the
ISS huge radiators finally dissipate it
into
space ammonia is used because unlike
water it doesn't freeze until - 107° F
light it remains liquid and flows
through the
radiators even when the ISS is behind
the Earth ammonia is used as a heat
rejection system because it is one of
the best thermodynamic fluids to use as
a heat rejection fluid unfortunately
it's incredibly toxic and kills human
beads on
contact in May 2013 for reasons unknown
a amonia is spotted leaking out of one
of the cooling
pipes there is no alternative but for
astronauts to climb outside the ISS to
fix
it fireflies coming off our space
station the International Space Station
has a network of vital cooling pipes
that are filled with ammonia a substance
so toxic it can
kill now there was a time in 2013 when
Chris Hadfield and his crew spotted a
leak from the ammonia pipes um and they
had to react very very quickly to stop
that that leak the leak appears near one
of the solar panels there's only one
viable response to this critical
emergency astronauts Chris Cassidy and
Tom marshburn must exit the ISS and
investigate sunlight I am putting my
visor
[Music]
down they discover ammonia spewing out
of what they think is a
pump fireflies coming off our space
station if they can't stop the flow they
might have to evacuate the space
station you're going to monitor for an
ammonia leak if uh some reason a flowing
leak is observed immediately sto turning
the pair attempt to replace the suspect
pump hard work encumbers some space
suits and they must avoid contact with
the potential lethal
ammonia be careful uh not to put your
hand inside that window and also the
seals on the fqc are no
touch no touch on the seals don't
penetrate the window copy
off 5 and 1 half grueling hours later
the astronauts returned to the is says
unharmed that's affirmative the ammonia
valve is
closing it was fortunate that the leak
wasn't water because along with oxygen
water is one of the precious Commodities
people cannot live
without it's so precious in fact that
inventing equipment to recycle it was
one of the space station Engineers
highest
priorities it's so important that that
we recycle as much of the water on the
ISS as as possible and that includes
things just like um the the water in the
air the end goal is for the spacecraft
to recycle 100% of their onboard water
that's far from straightforward because
much of it starts off inside the
astronauts that water vapor comes from
the from the individuals as you breathe
you exercise you sweat and then it comes
off of your off of the surface so that's
the water vapor that gets out into the
air and we're constantly ventilating the
air through the
module water VAP from the air is
collected in a condenser every droplet
is valuable nothing is wasted even urine
is recycled let's say you're a pan ISS
and you need to go to the restroom you
want to come to this cabin and the first
thing you want to do is grab this piece
of equipment and turn this rotter switch
90° to the open position what that does
is it turns on a fan which creates a
suction effect in this hose so that you
can use this yellow element for your
number
one after an astronaut uses the unusual
facility Water Products flow to the life
support rack where filters get to work
the start of a sophisticated
process so the way space station turns
urine into water is that the urine goes
into what we call the urine processing
assembly there are a number of stages
the first is treating the urine to
prevent buildup of bacteria or other
dangerous
microbes that urine that we collect from
the crew we have to add chemicals to it
in order to process it raw urine in and
of itself would be a problem because
over time it becomes rancid and uh
that's uh definitely a bad situation on
the space station so that's why this is
a dark fluid instead of what you would
normally think of as urine clearly that
is not drinkable it needs to be
distilled where pure water is boiled off
to leave the toxic waste products behind
and then it goes through another
cleaning process there's lots of filters
and then some of the water is made
available for drinking and that's why we
have the expression that the water
recycling system is coffee to coffee you
can think about that the water that gets
to the crew now is effectively cleaner
than any water that we drink here on
Earth even that nice bottled water that
everybody likes so much it's cleaner
than that uh so this is the end point in
the process it tastes really
good in water recycling we are really
trying to get to the point where we can
recycle up to 90 or 95% of the water on
the space station which is really vital
not only for going someplace like Mars
but also has um consequences here on
Earth recreating the conditions that
support life on Earth is one of the
pillars of the
ISS but much of its equipment is still
operated by Mission Control in
Houston the ISS will have to break free
from that if we're ever going to conquer
deep
space we're going to have you go to the
ticker shroud removal
[Music]
okay the international space station
provides its own life
support but it's partly controlled from
Earth y it
[Music]
[Applause]
okay our flight controllers on the
ground can control the robot arm and
move that from the ground that requires
constant radio
communication a major challenge because
radio wave can't penetrate the earth and
the ISS is often behind it what a
beautiful piece of
Hardware we can have significant loss of
signal with the space station we're
talking in the order of maybe 12 to
maybe 40 minutes maybe a little bit
longer in the early Apollo space
missions they tried to fix the problem
with a fleet of jets that bounced radio
signals between each other ground bases
and space capsules but it was expensive
and
unreliable the ISS uses a more
sophisticated
system there are various assets that we
are able to use to communicate with the
International Space Station so one are
via satellites a network of high orbit
satellites relay radio data between the
ISS and ground bases in several
countries across the globe and Mission
Control we're looking at various video
feeds so we have the first Board of over
here we call it the six-pack and the
International Space Station allows at a
minimum six down link video channels and
then we can be following the crew what
they're doing during their day station
Houston on Space to ground 2 you have a
go for step six ingressing
Dragon the live links are so reliable
and fast there is now less than a
seconds delay when astronauts
communicate with Earth hi
Dad hi Dad how are you hey Rob hey bud
how's it
going currently looking at what we call
the world map it would show that the
International Space Station is currently
about to start swinging north of
Antarctica another cool feature about
the world map that we keep in front of
the control room is the fact when other
missions go and launch we'll also see
those Vehicles where they are relative
to the International Space Station
3 2 1 engine ignition lift off of the
falcon9 rocket the ISS may still be in
our local space neighborhood with the
luxury of near instant
Communications but it's also our first
stepping stone to reaching other planets
and Beyond with science for today and
for deep space exploration
tomorrow inside this rocket is an
experimental new modu modle known as
beam the first human rated expandable
structure to be flown in space now
attached to the International Space
Station after docking with the ISS
astronauts test its unique feature it
blows up like a
balloon it's an inflatable module that's
attached to the space station um it's
kind of unique in that the fact it is um
inflatable looks great it looks
pristine pressurized air pumped into the
extraordinary new module transforms it
into a rigid
structure one of the unique things about
beam is that because it is collapsible
you don't need as large of a launch
vehicle to carry it also potentially
less weight because of less structure
with it if successful the iss's brand
new living quarters could lead to much
bigger space
structures ultimately the plan is to
house far more than than the 220 people
that have so far been to the space
station we've been very privileged we've
we've seen our home planet from a very
different
perspective first of all it's incredibly
beautiful I mean you look at the The
Thin Blue Line that's our atmosphere you
look at the Aurora you look at
thunderstorms you look at the the
beautiful
oceans when you start looking a little
closer there are some troubling things
you basically see the impact that humans
have had on our planet and that could be
pretty scary at
times the long game for Humanity could
be to stop being a one planet
species the ISS is the first step
towards that
future in the future we're going to have
hundreds thousands I hope it's 10,000s
of people living working in lowth orbit
research on the ISS is heavily geared
towards improving life for astronauts
who will travel much further than ever
before it's phenomenal so it really is
the world's greatest
laboratory on Space Station a lot of the
experiments that they're doing are
human-based experiments in order to
learn more about the human body so that
we can endure a two two and a half year
Mission to Mars and
back from Fitness to food production the
focus is on long-term self-sufficiency
for
astronauts and we are developing the
Orion capsule here which will be
launching the first man mission in
2022 and liftoff at dawn the dawn of
Orion and a new era of American space
exploration missions in the coming years
are only possible because the
International Space Station has solved
so many of the problems that space
presents
the future for space is bright and it's
going to be exciting everybody is
excited and feel like as though in this
development phase you can really make a
difference the ISS is an incredible
super
structure a piece of earthlike habitat
floating above our planet where every
component has taken breathtaking
engineering it's now a vital springboard
board for deep space travel that
generations to come might thank us
[Music]
for